Pour ne louper aucune vidéo, abonnez-vous
et activez la petite cloche !
Un bon coup de chiffon, indispensable
pour les bulles. Mais d'où sortent-elles ?
Ça donne envie de s'y plonger hein ?
Pas dans le champagne... dans les bulles !
Un peu d'Histoire... de petites histoires !
Selon la légende, la méthode
d'élaboration du champagne aurait été
mise au point à la fin du XVIIe siècle
par un moine, Dom Pérignon, à l'abbaye Saint-Pierre d'Hautvillers, aujourd'hui
située dans le département
de la Marne près de Reims.
Pour être tout à fait honnête, la recette
n'est pas totalement sortie de son cerveau.
Il se serait inspiré d'une méthode
élaborée initialement dans le
sud de la France dans la région de
Limoux près de Perpignan.
Ah ça je l'ignorais ! Au prochain dîner
c'est sûr, je me faire mousser !
Les bulles du champagne viennent du gaz
carbonique, le CO2 contenu dans le vin.
C'est le même gaz qu'on injecte
en grande quantité dans les canettes de soda
pour que ces boissons soient pétillantes. Dans le champagne, le CO2 n'est pas injecté.
Il se développe naturellement dans le vin
et je vais vous montrer.
Pour faire du champagne,
il faut du raisin.
Traditionnellement, les vignerons champenois utilisent
trois cépages, trois variétés : du Chardonnay,
du Pinot Noir et du Pinot Meunier qui sont
assemblés. le raisin est pressé,
on récupère le jus qu'on appelle le moût, qu'on laisse
fermenter dans de grandes cuves comme celles-ci.
Le sucre présent dans la
pulpe du raisin se transforme
en alcool et en gaz carbonique qui
s'échappe librement étant donné que ces
cuves ne sont pas fermées hermétiquement.
D'ailleurs, ça se sent un peu.
Jusque-là, le processus est exactement le même
pour tous les vins, qu'ils soient blancs ou rouges.
Ce qu'on appelle
des vins tranquilles.
Ces caves ont été creusées il y a 800 ans,
pour construire la ville de Château-Thierry.
On va peut-être s'activer un peu  ? Parce que là
je ne sais toujours pas d'où sortent les bulles.
J'y viens !
Pour le champagne, la suite
de l'histoire est différente.
Au lieu de vieillir en fut, le champagne
est mis en bouteille.
À ce stade on ajoute du sucre et des
levures. Commence alors la deuxième
fermentation alcoolique. Les levures transforment le sucre en gaz
carbonique, un gaz carbonique qui ne peut
pas s'échapper cette fois puisque
la bouteille est fermée. C'est ce qu'on
appelle la prise de mousse. Le champagne
qui jusque-là était un vin tranquille se
transforme en vin effervescent,
naturellement chargée en gaz carbonique.
On se réveille !
Oh ! Excusez-moi...
J'étais dans ma bulle.
J'observais le dépôt qui se forme durant
cette étape. Les bulles de champagne, elles,
ne sont pas visibles. Pour qu'elles se forme,
il faut déboucher une bouteille.
Les bulles ne se voient
pas parce que le gaz est dissout.
Une bouteille comme celle-ci
contient 75 centilitres de liquide
et du gaz. Du gaz qui lorsqu'il
se retrouve à la pression atmosphérique
occupe un volume 6 fois plus grand
que cette bouteille.
Autrement dit, cette bouteille de 75 centilitres
piège 5 litres de gaz, 5 litres qui se retrouvent
sous pression à l'intérieur de
la bouteille. Cous comprenez maintenant
pourquoi le verre des bouteilles de
champagne est si épais. Pour résister à
la pression qui règne à l'intérieur : cinq
à six fois la pression atmosphérique.
Pour vous donner une idée,
c'est la pression qui règne
à 50- 60 mètres de
profondeur dans l'océan.
Au passage, voilà à quoi ressemble au
départ le bouchon qui va remplacer la capsule
une fois qu'on a
évacué le dépôt.
Il est beaucoup plus large
qu'un bouchon classique.
Pas vrai
mon p'tit bouchon ?
Il est enfoncé de force dans le
goulot mais le frottement du liège
contre la paroi n'est pas suffisant pour
résister à la pression. Il faut rajouter
ce que l'on appelle un muselet, très utile
également au moment où on débouche
la bouteille. Attention,
il faut bien le retenir car
avec la pression, le bouchon peut être
éjecté à plus de 60 kilomètres par heure.
Les voilà enfin les petites bulles.
Maintenant que la bouteille est ouverte
et que la pression a brutalement chuté,
le gaz carbonique cherche à se détendre
et à s'échapper. Mais pour cela, pour se
détendre,
il lui faut de l'espace. Eh bien il le
trouve dans le verre, plus précisément sur
les poussières qui sont collés au fond
et sur les parois.
D'où l'intérêt de donner un coup de torchon
avant de servir le champagne.
Poussières atmosphériques, fibre déposée
par le torchon grossies des milliers de fois,
voilà à quoi ressemblent ces poussières.
La surface très irrégulière comme vous
pouvez le constater, héberge, des
petites bulles d'air.
Le CO2 va s'y glisser et se détendre,
il y prend sa forme gazeuse. Quand la bulle
est assez volumineuse, elle se détache
et s'élève comme une montgolfière.
Merci les petites mains !
Puis, une autre bulle se forme etc etc.
En montant,
les bulles de champagne
se chargent encore plus de gaz carbonique,
elles prennent du volume et se chargent
aussi de molécules aromatiques.
Parvenues en surface, elles éclatent.
Et pourquoi
les chaussures de sport ?
Parce que l'éclatement des bulles projette des microgouttelettes
à la vitesse de 15 mètres par seconde,
un tout petit peu plus vite que la vitesse
d'Usain Bolt, le champion jamaïcain au 100 mètres.
Une ne poussière peut donner naissance à
une quinzaine de bulles.
On a compté : un verre comme celui-ci peut
produire jusqu'à 1 million de bulles.
1, 2, 3, 4, ...
Cette espèce d'embrun, comparable à celui
qui se forme au-dessus des vagues de l'océan,
permet de sentir
les arômes du vin.
Quand on approche le verre de son nez, et
cela avant même qu'on ait le champagne
en bouche. Une dernière chose...
Flûte ou coupe ?
Dans une flûte, le champagne
pétille plus longtemps, la colonne de bulles
et plus haute est la surface de contact
avec l'extérieur est beaucoup moins
grande que dans une coupe. Surtout pas de
gobelets, même en carton ! La surface
intérieure de ces derniers est
recouverte d'une pellicule plastique
pour les rendre étanches.
Le problème c'est que les bulles
adhèrent à ce matériau. Bon bah... on va pouvoir déguster !
...1 million !
Ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
pousser le bouchon un peu loin.
N'oubliez pas,
le champagne c'est à
consommer avec modération. Quant aux
vidéos, vous pouvez vous resservir autant
que vous voulez ! Allez,
joyeux noël et à très bientôt.
Mince ! Bah mince alors...
C'est pas possible ! C'est pas possible !
Là ça va péter tout de suite...
J'y vais.
Mais je rêve ou quoi !?